- [Instructor] Let's say
that we are in deep space,
and there is this asteroid here,
that compared to us, is stationary,
or relative to us is stationary.
And what we wanna do is
we wanna start to move it.
So what we do is we attach
a rocket to one side,
and then we ignite that rocket,
and it starts to send all
this super-heated gas,
all of these particles to the right.
Well, what do you think that's
going to do to the asteroid?
Well, it's going to push on
the asteroid in that direction.
Or you could say it's
going to exert a force
on that asteroid.
And we could show that force like this,
where the strength of that force,
or the magnitude of the force,
is the length of this line.
And then the direction,
I will specify or show with that arrow.
So fair enough, I will be
pushing towards the left.
And when I push to the left,
it doesn't just start to move
the asteroid to the left,
it actually will accelerate
the asteroid to the left.
So the longer that this rocket is running,
it's going to make the
asteroid move to the left
faster and faster and faster.
But let's think about another example.
Let's say that you and
one of your friends,
you have a little bit of miscommunication,
and they went and put an identical rocket
on this side of the asteroid.
And y'all ignited it
at the exact same time.
So this one is going to
push in the other direction.
What do you think is going to happen
if these happened at the exact same time?
Even though there's
now twice as much force
being exerted on this asteroid,
it's going in opposite
directions, so they zero out,
and so there's zero net force.
And so this asteroid won't
be accelerated at all.
Now let's say that a third friend
wanted to correct this situation,
and this isn't necessarily the
most efficient way to do it,
but what they do is they
put another identical rocket
right over here, and
let's say ignite that.
Now what will happen?
Well, now you had the original two forces
that net out to each other.
But now you have this also this new force,
which I will make in purple,
'cause it's a purple rocket.
And so that new force,
you could draw like this,
to show, all right, that
will now be the net force,
'cause you have the
equivalent of two rockets
going in the left direction,
and one rocket going
in the right direction.
Or another way we could draw that is
we have two rockets going
in the left direction,
so that would have a force
that looks like this.
And then we have one going
in the right direction.
And so if you were to net it out,
this is equivalent to
just having one rocket
that we originally saw.
That's equivalent to just going back
to what we originally saw.
So the important takeaway from this video
is that it's not just about
the force that's being applied.
If you wanna think about how something
might be accelerated,
and in what direction,
you need to think about the net force,
because some of the forces
could counteract each other.